des personnes nous écrivent l'une des
vosges l'autre de belgique encore pour
nous commander le même micro trottoir
sur la section il s'agit souvent
d'ailleurs cessé pas téléguidée par il
s'agit de deux étudiants françois de
grave de bruxelles brussels de et claude
martin de château qui veulent là et
l'autre obtenir un diplôme de sexologie
présente une étude très sérieuse sur la
débauche et il voudrait faire précéder
la présentation de leur mémoire d'une
courte séquence vidéo dans l'esprit des
micro trottoirs de gérard pâtes bio
notre licenciés etc sexualité bon tiens
j'avais pas levé cette réputation
et comme je partais précisément belgique
à la réception de vie de votre lettre
monsieur de grave je vous dédie donc ces
quelques au pignon sur rue alors claude
martin des vosges et vous même monsieur
deux graves selon la formule consacrée à
vos magnétoscopes
avez vous entendu parler d'inceste et
dans quelles circonstances monsieur dans
les boissons dans les boissons vous ai
entendu parler d'un set alors qu'est ce
que c'est que l'inceste morceaux de
citron ou un morceau d'orange à votre
avis l'hétérosexualité qu'est ce que
c'est bon je pense que l'hétéro viennent
du des terres donc c'est cette drogue à
lesterps ce s'envoyant en l'air on se
droguant avec de l'éther mais ce film
est malade qu'est ce qu'ils vont dire
pourquoi six infirmières je fais le
domicile et jamais vous n'avez pratiques
et l'hétérosexualité homophiles qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
bon au mot et film on décompose le mot
un homme ou d'un fils aussi au bout d'un
fil ce serait quoi l'on abat n'a manqué
que décroche un téléphone peut être des
cas donc est ce que c'est votre avis dk
m à paris ça me dit que dix cas qu'un
caddie dans les camps mais ça veut dire
quelqu'un qui dit dans des cas mais ça
veut dire dit m donc un personnage
décadent c'est un caddie dans un
personnage car c'est rien que 10 des
recettes 10 des cas le mot licencieux
est ce que vous connaissez
oui mais je dors dans à licencieux
autrement dit qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
licencieux c'est ali où il n'ya pas de
toi je pense de toit de toile au dessus
de la tête de la personne bon et alayli
avec ce bon il ya les rideaux bon qui
empêche justement dans le temps mais
c'est ça pour les moustiques
on m'a dit vous m'avez dit que vous
n'auriez pas avec un licencieuses oui je
n'ai pas de licence yeux réalisme
trouvez vous normal monsieur qu'une
femme fasse le trottoir non pas du tout
du moins pour le pavé ou pas là disons
qu'elle peut le ballet il parle pas le
construire quoi parle pas vu à le faire
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire que c'est
pas normal parce qu il ya des travaux
qui doivent être resté bien dans le
domaine des hommes c'est plus un homme
de faire le trottoir cas une femme pour
le pavé avez vous entendu parler madame
de déviation sexuelle
oui c'est à dire qu'il ya quarante ans
que je conduis mais je connais des
déviations
mais pas sud et ville qui s'appelle
sexuelle sais pas comment sexuelle
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça qu'on
dit depuis très longtemps et j'ai déjà
vu beaucoup de déviation par tous mais
le wiels actuelle c'est différent
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle un adultère
c'est un enfant quand les jeunes après
s'adressant quand on grandit on dit que
l'état du terrain gardez-vous par
exemple la barre des 100 pts et adultère
je suis adulte hermes cc vous qu'est ce
qui vous fait dire ça là bas qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un adulte et un mois c'est
ça quand on grandit et devient de terre
autrement dit la barre fait l'adultère
voyez vous la différence entre un ballet
bleu et un valet rose par exemple
différence c'est le même qui soit rose
qui soit bleu qui soit russel mâle elle
même
il faut tout ça ménages principal c'est
que je sais faire le ménage
si je vous dis ça donne ça donne ça
double ce peut être sa douce à dos ses
dépens la grandeur du sceau du sceau du
sud où lui du sceau d'eau pas du sodium
plus tôt dudus aux dom se nomme alors
sodome qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
assaut en métal donc qui est prévu
justement généralement pour être
employés par un homme à part par une
femme et un enfant
si je vous parle de sadowa la salle où
ça dépend pas ce que ça donne ça peut
être ça c'est peut être ça ça se demande
à quoi la quantité la quantité de quoi
tout par rapport à quoi
la grandeur du sous le nom de quoi
sodome il le tue sous-hommes voilà ça
c'est pas un enquêteur sadique dans ses
vergers en famille ou bien évidemment
non
voyez où ce qu'on appelle rouler au pas
monsieur l'a roulé au pas c'est marcher
un peu comme comme ça enfin est moins
brillant
alors là vous roulez repas
un peu quoi pourquoi ou le ton en bas
alors faire épater les filles
qu'appelle-t-on un doctorat bohemen
doctorat bon c'est un docteur monde qui
serait bon à la tête d'une ville ou d'un
pays
bon qui seraient prises dans la
république comme le docteur schweitzer
pays alors le docteur choisi au gabon je
pense et ça c'est un doctorat parce que
c'est le docteur schweitzer qui est le
patron ben oui mais bon qui serait à la
tête de ce pays ou encore maintenant oui
je pense oui et c'est quel pays vous
m'avez dit le gabon à votre avis
l'hexagone qu'est ce que c'est c'est
donc à deux côtés un quoi un rond que du
côté de côté oui vous êtes sur wii
comment imaginez-vous le front national
le fonds national bert dégarnis sur le
dessus bien en arrière
quelques rides une petite pour donner
l'air un peu soucieux un petit béret
puisqu elle je vois pas d'autre chose
le 14 juillet ça vous dit quelque chose
qu'est ce qui s'est passé le 14 juillet
ça a été la fin de la guerre 39 45
qu'est-ce qu'on fait le 14 juillet 4 j
en fait
ce qui s'est passé à la bastille il est
avec les syndicats fo cgt tout ça et
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ce jour là ils
ont manifesté pour avoir un accord un
accord de coin un accord avec le
patronat tout ça si je vous parle du
carré de l'hypothénuse
chais pas en ouverte
c'est un fromage d'auvergne le carré de
l'hypothénuse
à votre avis enfin quand je vous en
parle on vous dit quelque chose quand
même
oui oui mais moi j'ai ouvert les jeudis
allergologues bas golog je pense que ça
se rapproche à google golog se rapproche
de gogol qui veut dire quoi
un peu bêtes et on le dit dans quelles
circonstances
quand on voit quelqu'un qui est qui et
pas parce réfuté quoi en fait on dit
quoi et hilaire google ou golog je
suppose il al'air blog ouais mais vous
vous dire il ya plutôt google google
catalog
qu'est ce que c'est que la table de
logar c'est une table qui remplace
trois ou quatre musiciens des fois et
qu'est ce qu'on trouve sur sept tomes de
plusieurs définitions de chansons comme
me donner un exemple la la la contacts
sont ceux-là je ne sais pas - c'est des
joueurs comme ça quoi de savoir quand
même oui moi je sais pas ce que j'en ai
vu mais on avait vu ou des tables de
logarithmes surtout dans les orchestres
qui servent de tout ça oui
enfin pour moi que j'ai vu il n'a
peut-être pas roussir l'étape de
logarithmes oui peut-être
les mathématiques ou des trucs comme ça
non non pas de table de logarithmes les
maths sûr c'est sûr non
voyez vous c'est qu'elle bassin
méditerranéen où il va s'arrêter mais
moi j'aime bien les femmes qui sont bien
en chair bien dans leur bien dans leur
peau bien quand le quand le cul un peu
gros voyez vous le cul si vous parlez ce
point c'est pour employer un mot trivial
et le bassin parisien alors ce serait
quoi
ben ça serait plutôt des femmes qui ont
les hanches plus minces à votre avis
qu'est-ce qu'un oiseau migrateur
opérateurs des deux pays en temps ils
grattent la terre pour un nouveau tueur
hippie dans la terre alors pourquoi
migrateurs migrateurs gratteur pour ce
qui grattent la terre et je me gratte
juste migrateurs migrateurs bon gratteur
se dire qu'ils grattent la terre et il a
admis gratteur et la demie puis coeur et
pourquoi piqueur la pick up et c'est
pourquoi pour prendre la nourriture dans
la terre et gratteur gratteur c'est
aussi pour votre sénateur d'en la terre
alors il est migrateurs voilà me piqueur
mais au vu un ni quoi ni migrateurs unis
ficr dans un crime gabelle temps le
mobile je lui qui peut bouger en
opposition à quoi l'on a chez lui qui
est mort qui peut pas bouger et qui
serait quoi lui la victime ayant le
mobile c'est le tueur
pourquoi et puisqu'il peut évoluer que
l'enseignement si je vous dis ça non
ado c'est peut être ça dos à dos ses
dépens la grandeur du so nice au delà du
seau d'eau du seau d'eau va du sodium
plutôt du sodome sodome alors surnomme
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un saut en
métal donc qui est prévu justement
généralement pour être employés par un
homme à part par une femme un enfant et
si je vous parle de sadowa là ça donne
ça dépend pas ce que ça donne ça peut
être ça ça doit être ça ça se demande à
quoi la quantité la quantité de quoi
d'où par rapport à quoi
la grandeur du sou ils sont quoi
sous-hommes une puce odom vous avez
entendu parler de cette expression la
langue de shakespeare ouija d'année mais
pourquoi dit-on la langue de shakespeare
votre avis je sais que lui vétroz qui ça
j'espère qu'ils vont à vétroz
et alors et alors on comprenait pas ce
qu'ils disent est pendant et moi j'ai eu
tous et des voix presque jusqu'aux du
premier jusqu'au 6e et après j'avais été
jusqu'au sixième livre jusqu'au sixième
livre après j'ai arrêté presque mieux
que j'écrivais on comprend pas ce qu'il
disait parce qu'à cause de salon après
quoi ça lag et on comprenait pas ce que
l'enquêté comme un bleu un peu bleus et
qui réunit la cause de la boisson
bp c'est tout après j'ai arrêté j'ai eu
entre autres les personnes qui buvaient
moins voilà si je vous dis chantons sous
la pluie
labourage est pas tout si je vous dis
chantons sous la pluie
je ne sais pas chanter mais je sais
faire un poème labourage et pâturage sur
les mamelles est le fruit de la terre
cela vaut mieux faire l'amour que faire
la guerre et détruire tout le monde et
chantons sous la pluie
hélas les choses étant ce qu'elles sont
vous parlez vous et sans se parler de
chantons sous la pluie il faut épouser
son fils
non mais chantons sous la pluie ça vous
dit rien non il ne peut pas en ce moment
parce que il fait du temps gris j'adore
ça ne vous dit rien j'entre on me dit
rien non mais vous irez de terre dans
l'espace vous donnera la possibilité de
créer en 120 on s'en va on s'en va quels
documents accablants moralité chers
téléspectateurs si vous apercevez
l'ignoble barbu d'abord de dans la rue
avec un micro changer immédiatement de
trottoir
dans notre abondant courrier le problème
des assurances revient beaucoup plus
souvent qu'à son tour dans les
automobilistes se plaignent en général
que l'on ne respecte pas le contrat et
les assureurs eux estiment que c'est le
code de la route qui n'est pas toujours
respectée dans le premier cas nous
essayons d'intervenir auprès des
assureurs vous voyez dans cette émission
nous faisons assez souvent et pour ce
qui est du code de la route
eh bien nous avons soumis ce petit
lexique proposé par gérard tableau pour
éviter les accidents de la circulation
trafic avec dont les chemins vicinaux
madame on est bien à ces cantons c'est à
dire c'est pour aller quand on veut
aller aux toilettes faire un brin de
toilette avant de passer à table et
comment nourrissent pas dire
l'expression donc baisser on dit
vicinaux andy cette expression on a
commencé les sino les chemins vicinaux
sino voilà en direct et en disto mollahs
à la place pour vouloir dire quoi pour
vouloir dire mes wc quoi ewc on prend
auriez-vous volontiers les grands axes
mode homme les prêter oui à quelqu'un
que je connaîtrai mais autrement
emprunter no pourquoi je ne sais pas
c'est mon tempérament comme ça j'aime
mieux prêter que d'emprunter voyez ce
que c'est que les grands axes est ce que
c'est la rn13 ça vous dit quelque chose
oui c
une reine dans son mari était le 14 ou
vous 13 qui eux qui gouverner un peuple
quel peuple à un peuple un peuple sait
pas vraiment quel pays france comment
faut-il s'y prendre pour supprimer les
points noirs de la circulation
ben faut laisser faire la nature fallait
faire ça guérit tout seul peut-être par
mois voyez ce que je veux dire quand je
parle de points noirs de la circulation
oui bah oui puisque c'est mince et les
boutons circulation du sang on parle
beaucoup à certaines époques du pc de
ronnie qu'est ce que c'est que le pc de
ronnie monsieur c'est un siège quitte à
rogner du parti communiste qui était
souvent que pensez-vous les bretelles
d'accès et bien moi personnellement je
préfère la ceinture mais ça c'est chacun
tout un chacun moi je trouve que la
ceinture est plus rapide que les
bretelles les bretelles vous dirai ça
peut aller au tout aussi vite si vous
faites un côté l'autre sans faire
attention
ce serait quand même aussi vite dégagé
mais enfin le reste reste à voir le
résultat quoi la voie secondaire à votre
avis qu'est ce que c'est bah c'est ce
qui est derrière le chanteur par jean
basset ski
qui fait les choeurs derrière qui
reprend la voix du chanteur qui fait
quoi qui fait la la la la la la la la la
voie secondaire
c'est ce que vous en pensez vous des
voies secondaires pas plutôt chanteur en
lui même je pense que c'est la voie
principale mais voilà la boire principal
gabelt ont le sens province paris
ben c'est de paris il pense que les gens
de l'extérieur de paris qui sont qui
s'en fout et puis que la province ils
pensent que c'est pas les gens de paris
il s'en fout parce qu'ils ont chacun
leur sens de leur sens leur sens de leur
sens et leur vaut vous avez quoi le sens
province paris où le sens paris-province
le sens
romain ce pari c'est à dire c'est à dire
vous avez l'impression l'impression de
ne pas être comme ceux de paris
comment ils sont sept paris va il s'en
fout voyez où ce qu'on appelle rouler au
pas monsieur l'a roulé au pas c'est
marcher un peu comme comme ça enfin fait
moins rire
alors là vous roulez repas
un peu pourquoi ou le temps au bar alors
faire épater les filles pour faire
épater les filles
enfin comment on en fait moins world
voilà bah vous roulez drôlement biro pas
merci monsieur et bravo aux labos long
courriers que nous recevons mois pour
les micro trottoirs de gérard à biot une
réflexion revient très souvent au fil de
vos pages c'est normal que les gens ne
sachent plus rien les études ne sont
plus ce qu'ils étaient de mon temps on
apprenait les départements les
préfectures les sous-préfectures et ben
oui ça a bien changé pour se rendre
compte à quel point en cette période de
grandes migrations saisonnières monsieur
pas bio a voulu connaître sur l'eure là
somme de vos connaissances en faisant la
manche micro en main dans les rues de
montpellier pas quand je vous parle de
la somme en jeu c'est pas moi je parle
de lettre 10 ou 15 amis en couple à
seriez-vous la somme vous même immobile
quand je vous parle de l'anjou voyez ce
que c'est qu'est ce que ça peut être
c'est à dire quand on met le fusil il
convient et puis qu'on met la crosse
contre l'ajout n'avait pas l'air d'être
su comment se sont fait parce que je
n'ai jamais jamais jamais entendu parler
de l'anjou pourquoi parce que je n'étais
pas dans les gens qui maniait des armes
de service de sentiments ni probable la
meuse voyez ce que c'est que la meuse
oui ça fait je veux même pas s'il commet
jamais vu un pastis pourquoi la maison
et c'est quoi la meuse de la bière je
regarde une information presque tous les
jours mais jamais entendu parler de lyon
l'argent de la france est loin de
saint-etienne jamais jamais non je
connais très bien la région soutiennent
et de lyon vous avez jamais entendu
jamais non j'ai pas c'est même très
souvent est ce que vous en pensez vous
voulez vous je pense que s'il ya des
lions je suis peut-être que d'être lâché
par le manager ou placeriez vous l'aube
l'aube mais disons que moi je la
passerai plus tôt à l'est c'est à dire
les et la france l'a fait lire ça c'est
le soleil se lève à l'est et donc il me
semble que logiquement le soleil loupes
devrait apparaître le plutôt à l'aise et
la france si je prends la france comme
dans une grande ville de l'aube une
grande ville de lomme généré strasbourg
la touraine ça vous dit quelque chose à
touraine c'est dans le jus de la belote
en impôts on dit en tout cas tous très
fort en tout cas on ne vit pas à trouver
la touraine ça n'existe pas que
pensez-vous du pas de calais non mais là
je suis pas me parler du pas de calais
je sais pas qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
à votre avis non mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pas de calais à votre avis
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pas de calais
qu'est ce que vous entendez par
pas-de-calais
qu'est ce que vous entendez vous même
bar pas de calais mais moi j'ai entendu
moi je sais pour moi qui pose la
question c'est vous oui je vous dis pas
de calais je sais pas je vois pas ce que
voulait dire à votre avis et le
sancerrois alors ça serait quoi
c'est comme ça tu vois c'est à dire
alors à couper la tête à qui bah oui
c'est gea n'a d'autre il y en a un
paquet m
ben c'est devenu après ce d'être royaume
si c'est devenu la république alors le
sancerrois sur ce cas la république
ouais si je vous dis dijon 2 go de quoi
vous parlez
dijon de gens non dit jean jean dijon 10
jan je vous dis dijon ça vous dit
quelque chose dijon je vous prie de
m'excuser ont rejoint dijon
le jonc vous n'avez jamais entendu dijon
dijon ça vous dit jean jean à moins que
ce soit une ville à moins que ce soit
une videmment que ce soit à moins que ce
soit la vie la ville mais disons de
jeudi la gironde ça vous dit quelque
chose agir en iron ii c'est une femme
très bien fait avec des formes
avantageuses
vous voyez je vois pas du tout sept mois
voire alors la gironde une forme de joie
même très mal d longevilles mont d'or
dans le jura et royaliste et nous
commandent un micro trottoir ce qui
n'est pas incompatible pourquoi elle
serait ce dans un pays si forte
tradition monarchique nous écrit-elle je
m'étonne parfois d'une méconnaissance
aussi grande de notre histoire de france
les français vraiment ont la mémoire
courte
mieux vaut en rire ajoute ces dames 1
philosophie et c'est pourquoi j'aimerais
que gérard pas bio et constater de visu
l'étendue de notre méconnaissance sur le
sujet aussitôt écrit aussitôt faire
régulièrement
jacques chirac fait porter le chapeau
aux attentes de faire porter le chapeau
habité rend l inverse
qu'est ce que vous en pensez écoutez
c'est pas moi je vois très bien
mitterrand avec à chapeau oui c'est va
très bien et chirac
pourquoi pas avec un une casquette oui
c'est va bien mais je trouve qu'il est
bien le style pour porter ça voyez vous
ce qu'on appelle l' odeur de sainteté
monsieur bah c'est reconnaître une femme
qui est enceinte par son odeur qu'est ce
que vous en pensez mais le gens pensent
que toi sont même à l'oeil je veux dire
y'a pas de problème on le voit même
avant que ça sens je dirais salle et
vous toujours monsieur sur quel pied
danser une valse le tango par le pied
droit 1 passe à dhoble le pour calculer
les pieds en même temps je peux enfin
démonstration si vous voulez la wii
c'est pas difficile
on y va comme ça là vous voyez c'est moi
je suis pas très doué moi pour vous est
de piloter
oui oui mais pourquoi vos yeux c'est une
question qui surprend quand même dans la
rue et surtout de ce temps là et
pourquoi ça paraît évident que des
quileute et c'est à dire ma cassoulet je
vous dise moi tout le monde je pense que
tout le monde est culotté le sens là
c'est normal
culotté je pensais quand même trouver
quelqu'un dans la rue ce matin qui me
font ce genre de questions c'est à dire
m etes-vous culotté je pense que vous y
être que tout le monde y est moi je le
prouverai pas moi non plus à propos de
nana mouskouri que vous connaissez
j'aimerais vous parler du velouté de
savoir
j'en ai déjà mangé il s'agit de ce fait
avec de la crème et des champignons qui
sont sans doute de la savoie j'avais
entendu parler du van houten savoie nana
mouskouri
oui et qu'est ce que c'est c'était je
voulais dire c'est un potage c'est quand
on n'a pas de chance qu'on est dans de
beaux draps
ah bon dans de beaux draps oui mais moi
je préfère pas avoir de chance est dans
de beaux draps que d'être dans la dans
la chronique est sous les ponts je
préfère encore être dans des draps de
soie qui peut avoir de chance que pensez
vous des gens qui passent la main madame
n'aime pas vous aimez pas quoi je n'aime
pas ça même dans le dos ou sur le bras
j'aime pas qu'on me tripote donc si vous
rencontrez quelqu'un qui passe la main
nos mesures fines chif
que pensez vous madame des gens qui font
chou blanc mais ces questions des biens
jeudi gérer mais les choux et les
choux-fleurs
c'est à dire c'est à dire ces deux
légumes là principalement ça vous arrive
au bout de faire chou blanc quelquefois
à chaque fois que je fais cuire ses des
légumes mais comment faites vous alors
bien je les ai bouillante
je les plonge dans l'eau bouillante et
ensuite je les écoute et je les ai
refait clients normalement
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle les feux de
la rampe monsieur oui qu'est ce que
c'est
gadola mal aux fesses après s'être
glissé solar en temps quelqu'un ça vous
arrive des fois ça m'arrivait oui
annette aux gamins le général de gaulle
connaissez vous savez qu'il a connu un
moment donné la traversée du désert vous
savez également ce qu'elle a traversée
du désert oui parce que c'est un désert
que vous mais plusieurs motos qui
risquent leur vie et puis
genre c'est le bon courage quand même
parce que c'est pas évident à faire ça
serait ya pas mal de l'accident ni des
motos qui risquent leur vie et le
général de gaulle dans tout ça la banque
a versé du désert au pouvoir parce que
c'est la traversée du désert c'est un
dessert ça c est du sahb épandeur oui il
ya que du sable et puis beaucoup trop
niveau de ça et puis dans la vie du
général de gand enfin moi disons à peu
près parce que bon il a quand même
encouragé les personnes pour faire ça
déjà parce que je ne connaîtrais pas
beaucoup des forçats des chats pour le
général de gaulle j'avais entendu parler
dakar du général de gaulle et
d'enthousiasmé traversée du désert oui
c'est pareil dakar et puis alors le
général de gaulle qu'est ce qu'il aurait
fallu ben je crois qu'il a essayé de
faire la même chose quoi essayer de
participer au niveau des pilotes
il faisait quoi lui à lui est en train
de présenter comment ça se passait au
déroulement dans un hélicoptère
le général de gaulle général et groupe
paris dakar c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
traversée du désert
madame rené clément et oui c'est la
quatrième de l'émission debitel la
antibruit des âmes purgatoire d'un joli
nom nous écrit le 12 mars dernier un an
bientôt comme le temps passe n'est ce
pas jacqueline mais aussi comme vous
pouvez le constater avec nous deux il
faut garder espoir ce n'est pas parce
que vous n'obtenez pas une réponse
immédiate qu'il faut vous tracasser bref
madame clément avait des problèmes de
copropriété elle n'entre pas dans les
détails ou plus exactement c'est la
seule chose dont elle nous paraît ce
propos les termes employés dans la
lettre qu'elle a reçues ratifié entériné
quorum quitus délégation pouvoir
déontologie rétorsion coercition avec
cela écrit-elle gérard pas bio c'est moi
bonjour madame ne pourrait-il faire un
micro trottoir au que si madame clément
le voit signifie ratifié madame
fait la chasse aux rats voyou ce qu'on
appelle un train de vie oui c'est un
train ou c'est pas un wagon de
marchandises qui a pas de légumes qu'on
peut s'installer
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle le quitus
monsieur un produit qui tue les insectes
qu'est ce que ça signifie la déontologie
à votre avis ça signifie que la vente
que je sais pas on peut pas recevoir du
monde si on n'a pas à la maison qu'au
niveau où ça au logis à la maison une
expression vous connaissiez vous aviez
entendu déjà mesures de rétorsion et je
l'avais entendu oui mon beau frère qu'il
y en ait qui nous faisait ça votre
beau-frère parler de mesures de
rétorsion et pourquoi votre beau-frère
parlait-il de mesures de rétorsion alors
pourquoi le vêtement tombe bien quand on
dit le quorum par exemple de quoi
s'agit-il
cela est il que ce mélange de rome avec
c'est pas eu qu'une certaine qu'ils ne
sais pas à quoi avec certains liquides
mais quelle folle à faiblir mais moi je
peux faire leur home secte d'avoir comme
celle pour le quorum non pour leurs
hommes ou leurs hommes à pour le quorum
n'est pour l'europe alors le quorum on
m'avait dit c'est quoi c'est au niveau
de l'eau au mélange une certaine liquide
dans le quorum moi je préfère les roms
q'elle quorum quelques roms à votre avis
un embargo qu'est ce que c'est un bateau
comment un bateau qui peut arriver
jusqu'ici la voiture c'est un petit
bateau d'un petit bateau mais qui porte
beaucoup de monde sur ce bateau un
embargo
ben je pense que c'est le
la sciatique ce qu'on appelle la
sciatique et se défend de toute la
longueur des reins et ça vient rejoindre
on appelle ça le cap sur vettel entériné
qu'est ce que c'est mais entériné et
quand on entérine du foie gras ou du
pâté de lierre ou de la paix et tout est
ce que vous avez déjà entériné ou même
mais je vous dis ma spécialité c'est le
foie gras est un gestionnaire qu'est ce
que c'est
c'est un gestionnaire et pourquoi un
agent de police gesticule à nos
homologues qu'est ce que c'est c'est une
personne qui vante le sol dans quels
domaines alors pourquoi qui fait du
théâtre du théâtre ou alors malade
mental je sais pas moi qu'appelle-t-on
l'analogie c'est un terme médical qui
correspond à un tous les maux dans le
bas du dos comme les hémorroïdes et et
tout ce qui concerne
pourquoi analogies et non parce que ça
concerne ça vienne du bonus qu'est ce
que c'est qu'une mise en demeure les
filles qui sont sur le trottoir qu'on
aimait à l'intérieur quoi à l'intérieur
une maison
nous vous avions promis la semaine
dernière une suite au micro trottoir de
gérard tabio sur les illustres inconnus
alors et bien la voici comment se
fait-il que vous ne connaissiez pas les
essais de montagne et parce que je ne
les connais pas j'évite le temps des
aides nationales tout je connais arrive
je connais et steve ce que ça peut être
les essais de montagne à votre avis un
très bon joueur un joueur de vous
n'aviez pas entendu parler des eaux des
eaux mêlées de roger ikor alors qu'est
ce que ça serait d'après vous les hommes
et les deux roger ikor c'est un mélange
d'eau chaude et d'eau froide dans quel
but aux pratiques pour la cuisine pour
le nettoyage ou pour tous dans le désert
des tartares vous connaissez désert des
tartares de taizé oui et tartas et le
dessert oui ça y est c'est comment
nécessaire celles ci ont fait parler
comme ça l'arrosage mais quand je vous
dis la mort est mon métier
sympathique et c'est sabatier bouger
sabbatique à trouver le précieux excuse
la mort est mon métier
non c'est pas un métier c'est la vie il
ya les humains avec benoît a conduit à
galina mais si je vous dis alors mon
amour et mon métier quand elle à l écran
comment la vie et qu'on commence et
demande aux orteils si je vous dis la
femme de 30 ans de balzac
qu'est ce que vous en pensez la femme de
31 ans de balzac ça fait un peu jeune
pour balzac vu qu à mon avis ça doit
être une question d'argent
je connais beaucoup de
deux femmes 30 ans qui vont avec des
personnes de 55 à 56 entre 55 et 65 ans
juste pour une question d'argent c'est
pourquoi vous me dites chapeau votre
balle jaune parce que balzac déjà est
une personnalité personnes déjà riche
d'avoir un bundle wii
alors donc la femme de 30 ans si justin
les hauts de hurlevent ça vous dit
quelque chose
non non qu'est ce que vous connaissez
les vous ferrez celle attendue par liszt
compositeur
si je vous dis agatha christie a fait
dix petits [ __ ]
pourquoi parce que c'est bien possible
que va se disent à la fois que des quoi
hamel a fait dix petits [ __ ] les
valises entre alors dans sa vie c'est la
fête des mères dans sa vie qu'elle en
plus de 10 vous avez entendu parler de
la 25e heure de conte centre virgile
géorgie n'ont pas vraiment non mais
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
wentzinger je sais pas si facilement
réalisable mais réalisable il peut
descendre les lotos de travail à 25m 39
ou 35 certains par semaine avez vous
entendu parler de la trilogie de marcel
pagnol
je connais très peu mais enfin c'est
malheureux qu'il ait eu cette maladie
qui donc n'a cepe pagnol qui lui quelle
maladie en trilogie
qu'est ce que c'est la trilogie de votre
avis
c'est une maladie terrible certainement
enfin le rouge et le noir ça vous dit
quelque chose
oui mais c'est ça me dit quelque chose
pourquoi je fais deux tapisseries de
canevas et je n'aime pas très souvent
non le rouge et le noir
le petit prince de saint-exupéry ça vous
dit quelque chose oui bien sûr on ne
savait pas que c'est lui qui l'a chanté
comment est ce là lundi m'a fait
l'empereur sa femme et les petits 13
cents venus chez moi pour me serrer la
pince mais comme j'étais parti le petit
prince à des fils que nous reviendrons
masse 710 que joe perry apparemment oui
dit madame si je vous dis qui josé mais
est bien aimé moi
[Rires]
[Musique]